thank you and good afternoon everyone
can you hear me just fine like that yeah
cool
so yeah I'm Irina and for the past 10
years I've been working specifically on
computer vision object detection of the
cementation that kind of stuff and
currently at Jarama we're developing an
app that does augmented reality which
essentially means applying digital
effects to a live video a real-life
video that you could be recording with
anything for instance your phone
so that's used for things like
overlaying information on say mechanical
parts of some workshop but it can also
be used to do deeply satisfying things
such as this
yeah
so to in order to punch this guy's head
in you first need to find a head right
or his body and then extrapolate in any
case when your subject is facing the
camera is rather computer vision
techniques traditional ones tend to work
fairly nicely you can get a phase
detector fine on this kind of phase
she's she's facing the camera she's not
too far away that's fairly I'm not going
to say easy but it's it's done but when
the subjects are have a rotated away
from the camera or those wonky eye
angles of that camera or if they're
partially outside the frame or they're
occluded all sorts of things or they're
having a tantrum like the guy in the
video it starts to get pretty a little
more complicated to actually detect a
head the back of the head or any kind of
part and see that that's a person that's
the soldier that you want to apply your
effect on and so we turn to two deep
learning techniques because the
traditional computer vision was failing
us if you're hearing this as a
disclaimer it's probably because it is
so I'm trying to say that we didn't so
much hop on the deep learning hype train
as much as we were pushed onto it
because of the targeted use case we had
we wanted that extra flexibility and so
what invest journey we discovered was
was essentially this that the work that
you need to carry out to deploy a neural
network model on your phone starts way
way before you actually write any any
line of native code I may have the
attribution wrong but ignore it that the
quote still stands so what we were
asking ourselves was well okay there's
tons of detectors out there right what
architecture should we use how do we
actually deploy it how do we train it
how how do we choose and that's what I
would like to share with you the
approach that actually worked for us and
that made us be able to test different
things several days several every single
day instead of having to run models and
run trainings for a long time and maybe
lose our minds in the process
I'll go through the different phases
that we went through and how this was
configuration driven as in each every
each and every step was depositing a
part of the information in a deployment
file that's actually what went to the
phone where I wanted to run our model
and I'll go over a few of the pitfalls
and then talk about how we avoided them
so this pipeline will be will look
fairly familiar essentially you you
first need to find a design that works
for you you need to design your model
your your architecture you need to
prepare your data you need to decide
what data you need and and pre process
it you need to do the actual training
after that you'll get your actual
weights the ones that you want to load
on the phone but you first need to
evaluate what which one of all those
thousands of trainings that you've run
will actually work for you and we are
eventually all of that will go in your
deployment file and that's what you can
use on your phone so I'm going to stop
here and ask who has worked on computer
vision and is familiar with detectors
and classifiers raise your hand okay
very good
so but this is fairly basic for most of
you I guess a classifier will propose
what the label is for a given content so
it'll look at an image and say yep this
contains a person or yes this contains a
dog whereas Tector is in charge of
actually proposing a region for that
label and a bounding box around the
object so that's two two tasks but
inside it you can actually see a
detector as a classifier and a
localization module on top so the
classifier sure needs to come up with
labels it's been trained to know so if
it knows thousand classes that's exactly
what it would be able to predict but
then the localization module will need
to come up with suggestions of where
exactly inside your image that is that
object and what shape it has and
actually those two things classes and
the pre shape the pre shapes that you
can use or the templates that you can
use affect the size of your model
immensely
so again this needs to be deployed on a
phone so if you're going to be deploying
on our super cluster then you don't need
any of this sure go have fun if you're
going to be deploying or even on your
laptop that's fair enough there's tons
of architectures out there that run way
way over real time on a laptop or now
and the lab to use at work at home that
costs nothing on the market but if
you're going to be running it on on a
smart phone that perhaps sure a few of
them have three gigabytes of memory but
usually you'll have what a gigabyte to
and the computation power is way less
than the ten sixty that will be on your
or your laptop so you definitely
constraint but on top of that if you're
aiming again at an augmented reality app
eventually you're going to want to
integrate it into an engine such as
unity right because you need to get your
digital effects on that so that means
that if you're aiming at the the thirty
frames per second for the user
definitely your detector cannot run in
less than say 40 to 60 FPS so you really
need to get that very slim and very
quick so the first thing we did was okay
what's out there what can we use where
can we start and luckily there's a paper
published last year that actually did a
ton of that work for us I encourage you
to read it if you're curious about
different architectures that are
competing on imagenet this paper is
great and it's basically a survey of
available classifiers and on the x-axis
you you have the operations needed for a
single prediction and a single image and
on the y-axis you have the actual top
one label accuracy and the size of the
circles is is it's proportional to to
the actual parameters to the complexity
of your model so the bigger the circle
the more number of parameters on your
model so given that we wanted to deploy
a phone we definitely did not want to
have hundreds of millions of parameters
so part of that was definitely out
we're actually aiming to give you a
rough idea those v2g there you see it
it's two hundred and
almost 200 million parameters 100 or
something that translate into a several
hundred million several hundred
megabytes and we're actually aiming at
the size of say five megabytes so 1
million parameters 2 million parameters
maybe tops is what we wanted and the
same applies to operations we cannot go
too far to the right that's for sure so
what we want is maybe a family a family
of detector of classifiers that you see
in the in the still white area and we
wanted to boost the accuracy and slim it
down further so going back to the the
classifier versus versus a detector
thing if your detector is is going to be
at least 50% a classifier if that system
is going to be so important in the size
and the speed you definitely to start by
working on that so you're aiming at
reducing the memory footprint and the
inference time so what is the usual
suspect for 4 parameters in a model for
instance fully connected layers just
kill you and if anyone was here this
morning when tal was talking about
convolutional methods on text you see
that convolutional layers come up again
because they're great you can actually
translate your fully connected layers
into convolutional layers and that will
save you tons of parameters so one you
look for an architecture that is
convolutional e based and the other is
if you have layers that the architecture
of choice doesn't is not originally a
convolutional you can translate your
fully colored layers into that but then
you can you also have to think about
inference time right so a usual trick is
ok let's let's reduce the input size and
see how our model performs if that kills
the accuracy or if it it'll it'll stand
and there's other things that will also
reduce the rest of the layers and I'll
go back to that in a second because for
instance classes affect the size of your
layers and you want to keep that small
because again in the localization module
and there's two big things that
we'll make your model bloat one is the
number of classes and the other is those
template boxes that the model produces
to predict those that the bounding box
around your subject right and so if you
reduce those two things your
localization module will also slim down
and that will help you and then there's
there's a notion of that I'll get back
to a bit later on and it's that keep
only what you need so when you're
getting a model there's a bit of a cargo
called going on in that you get it and
you don't touch it because you don't
really know how it works well you need
to start asking yourself what's inside
that model and what layers you can
actually do without without actually
breaking anything so what exactly is
that layer at the end doing and can I
lose it if I remove it what happens if I
change it for something else that maybe
reduce the sit size what will happen so
at the end of the stage you basically
have an architecture that you that you
can at least you you think is promising
and that goes to that deployment file
that you pass on so at this point you
can think of it as a cafe proto txt if
anyone's been doing cafe lately it's
just a definition of your of your
architecture and yep at that point
you're ready to move through to your
data so you need to think what exactly
your users are going to be using so if
you're aiming at a self driven car then
the key to date and set is great but
again and you'll see it basically here
if I can see it not working okay it's
not really powerful enough anyway so
this one here becomes it belongs to the
kata data set so you'll notice that it's
a it's a fairly weird format so if
you're going to be deploying on an
iPhone for instance that's got like a
portrait aspect ratio and it's fairly
slimmer then maybe that will mess up
with your results you need to try it out
but in any case if you notice that the
kind of data present in a car data set
is not going to exactly be the ones that
you want to be using front of mented
reality app to use with your friends
right so maybe
the data said that contain pictures like
the one above where a bunch of people
are pretending to be some B's at a bus
stop will match a lot more the kind of
data set that you want so that first
step is okay let's see what exactly are
we going to be using what kind of data
we aiming at what format do we expect
and then what free data sets do we have
available to us and those three for
instance are all contained people
they're freely available free with
conditions associate we'll see in a
second but they're absolutely great
especially Pascal and cocoa which are
also challenges are really diverse and
there I'm great so yeah you've chosen
your intended use you're chosen you've
chosen your your format but then you'll
realize that since you're mixing and
matching datasets you won't expect them
to all have the same format right that
just doesn't happen so you'll need to
pay not with money but with time re
annotating and translating everything to
a format that you use internally in your
team and this goes back to another talk
this morning the golden the golden
standard data talk where mirror was
explaining about how you need to to to
decide how you're going to annotate for
instance and that was crucial for us
because you need to decide what actually
is a detection how you're going to be
drawing your boxes and you need to clean
up your data before you ever dream of
using it and there's also big part of
this in a consistency because even if
these datasets have very strong players
behind them they're not perfect and you
are going to find really disturbing
things in them where people were just
not when annotating them so you really
want to explore your data and fix it
simply clean it up so the first step is
that explore it and the second is
analyze it and extract statistics from
it because when you load your input data
on your phone you're going to want to do
things like normalizing it and you're
going to extract another very important
piece of information because again I'm
going back to to the predefined shapes
if you're going to be reducing the
number of shapes that you'll be using
you
want those to be representative of the
actual boxes that you have in your
target data right so you need to analyze
it and come up with with a with a good
with good representatives of what your
data will be and that goes to to that
deployment file which is sent forward
through the pipeline but before you move
on you also need to start tracking
things like what subsets of your data
set are you using to train is maybe not
or not everything is useful to you maybe
part is actually confusing your network
and you also want to start tracking the
augmentations you're applying to your
data while you're training but with that
you're fairly ready you've got your
statistics on the deployment file and
you can move on and you can actually
start training great because there's one
thing that's kind of known for deep
learning and that it requires a
humongous amount of data but what you
should remember is that it doesn't have
to be your data there's no need to train
from scratch unless your problem is so
specific to you that no one has ever
trained any model before that and at
least for object detection there's
several challenges like imagenet like
coca-cola like like Pascal where people
have already trained very expensive
models and publish those weights and you
can piggyback on that there's there's no
shame in that
so don't go at it alone just take one of
the pre trained models for instance for
those classifiers and transfer and use
transfer learning because one thing that
that holds for neural networks is that
the very early layers of any network is
a lot more generic so there'll be those
layers are learning things like like
edges there could be like Harlech
features so if you if you can reuse that
because after all an edge is an edge
whether you're detecting breeds of dogs
or people right it's it's still an edge
whereas the later layers in any network
will be a lot more specific and those
are the ones that you will want to
retrain so that's why you can in the
figure you can see part of the of the
network that has been frozen which is
fairly simple to do in cafe or intensive
flow if you free
those layers and those are the ones that
are not going to be to be retrained
because you trust them
those have been probably trained over
imagenet which has millions and millions
of images and you just retrain the later
the later layers to your specific data
set so cocoa or if you're able to
collect data from your users data from
them and at this point as usual you want
to track absolutely everything you try
out so if you're the hyper parameters
you're using to Train need to
automatically go into into those traces
and you need because you need to
evaluate whether they are hurting your
training or whether they are actually
working for you and it's and it's not
about going fancy and getting a
wonderful framework to that does have
hyper parameter tuning for you and it's
that's perfectly nice if you've got that
available to you by all means use it but
the only crucial thing here is that you
actually start doing it so if you're
using Jireh for tickets you can use that
to track the hypothesis you're going to
to test for your for your experiment
well I'm I'm guessing that this data
said will work better because bla okay
do that if you go into if you go if
you're using redline cool if you want to
just doing training dump everything you
use into a CSV that's perfectly fine
because after all any CSV you can feed
to any more sophisticated tool and
extract insight from it so it's fine
just start doing it so at the end of the
training or you get is your actual
training model you get the weights you
see realize them and that's what you'll
be deploying on the phone aside from all
the description of your network and and
everything that you'll be serializing as
well in that in that file and so one
thing that you'll want to do is evaluate
but what are you going to be looking at
because at least for me as soon as you
get a detection you you run your model
for the first time on images and and you
go wow look it's detecting it's working
right it's perfect but then you run
again and it picks up the body but it
doesn't pick up the head and then
someone comes up to you and say
well yeah sure the first one seems to be
working better because sure it picks up
a body and it picks up the head whereas
the other one doesn't but have you
noticed that the box the head box is
takes like part of the torso that
doesn't seem right so yeah that means
that you have to go back to to training
and it's even worse with some other
images which where is it's really not
that clear and in any case you
definitely do not want a human to sit in
front of thousands of images for every
single one of your hundreds of
experiments that's just not feasible so
clearly you need to go full data
scientist and adopt a metric and a very
popular one is a simple precision recall
curve where you want to make sure you're
minimizing either your false positives
and your false negatives and of course
you're going to be aiming at that top
right corner the one one where you're
supposedly not missing out any of the
detections that you're meant to be
detecting and you're not producing any
any new ones that are just not there and
if you'll notice every single of these
points are one model and one combination
of parameters that we were testing and
we know that our perfect model will sit
somewhere around up up to the right and
yeah this is just a sample of a whole
ton of models we which we were testing
insane so yep what things will you want
to be looking at you definitely want to
be tracking the architecture that you
were testing out you'll be tracking the
datasets that you read that you were
using because you'll probably want to
mix and match or you want to maybe
remove parts of those data sets because
you think they might be confusing the
network all of that needs to be tested
so that at some point you know what's
actually working and the augmentations
you're using will will vary depending on
your your your targeted use the hyper
parameters and the parameters by
deployment deployment parameters I mean
things like the confidence threshold so
sure you've got a prediction but how
what's the minimal threshold to consider
it really a human and so all of that is
what you're going to try to be
waiting and you need to be particularly
careful because the validation set could
also be biased very much so
so and or even not mirror the conditions
that you want to be working in if you
know that your app is going to be used
at night then maybe you want to make
sure that your validation set contains
tons of light images otherwise you just
want know which one works best but in
any case if there's one takeaway from
all of this at least for for me in this
journey is that you don't want to rely
only on the metric or only on human eyes
you need to rely on both you actually
don't want to say okay but has the best
mean average precision so this is the
best model not quite
you still need to run it over quite a
few images and lets someone else look at
them and especially if it can be
deployed on the phone and see if the
model is actually behaving smoothly and
anything it will solve your actual
problem but any case cool you've reached
your evaluation you've got your best
combination of parameters and you're
ready to deploy
so the key part here is that if everyday
you there's some some announcement of a
new framework I'm not sure if anyone has
tested out tents for full mobile I'm
really interested in knowing your
opinion if that's working out for you we
haven't tested it yet we're working with
working with metal cafe to uses metal
under the hood and we were targeting
iPhones so obviously metal performance
shaders is what's working for us but the
key here is the key point here is to to
try to find the framework that has
layers that you want to use because if
you choose a certain framework and
things are missing if you want to
implement the latest I don't know that
the latest paper from Facebook and it's
in certain layers are just not there
then you're going to have to rewrite
them from scratch so that's extra time
that you need to plan for and above all
what you do want is as soon as you have
any part of your network ready or more
or less thought of implemented and
deployed on the phone and make this over
fluid loop where you are designing
training evaluating and profiling on the
device very quickly even if you don't
have your detector ready if you even if
you only have the classifier be sure to
deploy it on the phone and test it out
on friends and see if it makes sense and
above all if it's fast enough because
again if your classifier is way too slow
on the phone sorry if it's running as I
don't know at seven FPS on the phone
then there's no way your detector is
going to reach those 60 fps so before I
finish I want to take a look at some of
the pitfalls that we found or more of
how we avoided them and the biggest one
to me would be the data sets because
again you need to sanitize them and we
found things with the annotations were
definitely not consistent even in within
the same data set all those freely
available ones are great they're the
best that you'll find without having to
hire someone to actually label every
single thing but you'll find that not
all the people and image have been
labeled or maybe crowds were just
labeled as one huge blob and well that's
supposed to be a person
you'll find that some detections are
missing or even what exactly should go
into a bounding box so for instance your
head bounding box if someone has very
long hair should their hair be
completely inside the bounding box or
what you defined and in any decision
that you make you need to make sure that
everyone's on board and if your
relabeling your data it needs to it
needs to reflect that those decisions
and a particular problem that we found
was for instance when we were playing
around with kitty kitty has cyclists
right but then other datasets have bikes
and have people so what's the cyclist
and if you have a bounding box that in
globes the bicycle with a human on top
you probably need to go through all of
your labels all of your images and re
label them right because you need to
separate the cyclists from the so you
actually you actually have to detect
people to real able data
that you're using for training to detect
people that just doesn't work so you
need to get creative about it and more
pitfalls the evaluation again I'll just
come back to that you really want to to
be evaluating in several ways not just a
metric metrics are great for challenges
that's how you beat a imagenet or the
koko challenge or whatever but you if
this is going to end up in a user app
you definitely want humans taking a look
at videos and seeing if your detections
make sense and if they feel good if they
if the bounding boxes actually fit the
subject because you should probably be
paying attention to that position recall
and maybe how the overlap so for
instance maybe intersection over union
of those bounding boxes but you also
want the human feeling of does this look
right even if it's just over a very very
small subset you also don't want any
humans involved in any part of the
configuration humans just break things
that's known so you want all of this to
be automatic and you want to be
systematic when you're tracking your
experiments that's a given
and again early profiling on the phone
saved us a lot of time even if it was
just part of the network just running
and taking a look at the output
activations if they made sense so if
you're taking a picture of a mug and
that has to be labeled a mug even if you
don't have the full thing running the
activation should be good and if already
just to feel a part of your network is
running way over your your targeted FPS
then then that's just not going to work
so yep so to sum up we've seen a few
tips that actually choosing your model
this pipeline that's based on a
configuration that's completely
automatic so that no human will break
anything and that will help you finally
deploy on your phone and a few of the
typical pitfalls so yep thank you and
any questions
excellent thank you so much I hope that
there are some good questions so if you
have a question please raise your hands
Jeffery will come around okay I will
wait wait
hello hi over here sorry
yeah thanks for the presentations great
I have a question about the the
libraries the image recognition
libraries
you mentioned image net the work
libraries the image libraries the data
sets
you mentioned image net yeah could you
repeat the others especially the ones
that are have different sets of objects
so they're all linking image that is
also something you can download if you
want to train from scratch let's here
you probably wanted to see this so you
want to take note kitsy is meant for
self-driving cars
Pascal and cocoa will Pascal is a bit
older it's from another challenge and
the ones that I like best personally are
cocoa and Pascal forward for use for day
to day pictures so they they feel more
more familiar more the kind of pictures
that anyone would take with their phone
or with a camera kit is very very
specialized it's great if you want to be
detecting cars bicycles trucks that's
what you want to go for any are they all
freely available and with different
formats
that's my gripe okay next question over
here fantastic presentation and
congratulation thanks not too long ago
in Ghana I don't know how you be
following issues in Africa a captain was
meted too badly and they have to track
the mop indicating who actually laid in
the Bedouin of the captain in suja in
Ghana 35 to 40 people's arrested
and the video that was shown it's like
there was no technique to actually
detect who did what and that is the kind
of challenges we researchers in Ghana
actually facing when there's a mob
attack and there's a video the images
how to actually count down the person
who actually did that so you take the
matter to court and the case is thrown
out because there is no real evidence
how is your research actually help us
both the academic communities and the
security agencies to actually track down
mob attacks or Madrid to mob that's
that's a very very good question so
there's there's two things that you
might want to look into one is scene
analysis and that's that's a very active
topic where people actually are trying
to interpret what's going on in an image
it's not just object detection which is
what this is about it's it's actually
seeing a video feed and interpreting
what is going on if they if there's
detection of several people moving in a
common direction - what's one single
person then maybe that's a potential
attack I'm not completely familiar with
that topic but maybe you want to read
into it there's another thing you
mentioned that they were they didn't
actually know who had done the mobbing
so you want maybe to look into
re-identification because it's not just
about detecting what a person is or
where they are but realizing that one
person is the same here than here so if
you've got for instance a database of
pictures seeing that the person in the
video is the same that you have in your
database so it's two related but not
exactly the same topics and in any case
this could help and for instance if you
have an IP camera going in places where
you know people shouldn't be there or
I don't know if you're in your office
and you know that not more than you and
maybe someone else should be there if
the count of detected bodies goes way up
then maybe there's some lobbying going
on or in parking lots or you know it
probably counting people might help you
but this to be honest this was meant
only for entertainment so this is just
for an entertainment app that there you
go there's those two other topics that
you might want to to read into
just a very quick question how long did
it take from the beginning to the very
end for this project from sort of
conception to having the model deployed
on the phone well the full journey maybe
a few months we started out trying out
with traditional computer vision
techniques and we actually have a
prototype running on that but then very
quickly we started trying out models to
be able to do this and the final app is
launching I don't have the actual date
but any day now okay as app is not ready
yet maybe it's not sure but are you
trying to get more training data from
the use that people will make off the
app for example if there's some clip
they want to share where there are these
boxing hands at the Hat for example we
did try to get this as okay it looks
like our model worked well there so we
can use it as training data without
trying to get training data from the use
of the app I really yes there's a whole
ton of of legal issues associated to
that so retrieving data from your users
is is tricky but yes that's something we
would like to do it's extremely useful
because it's exactly the kind of data
that you want to train on
Great Auk you talked about how you
basically track the versions how good
they are the different experiments track
the versions of experiments track the
versions like how good the models are
performing and such and stuff but if you
have like dozens or hundreds of models
that's kind of tricky and you said yet
do it and that's right but do you have
any good best practices there any
recommendation how you should do it how
you actually do it maybe yeah so doing
it incrementally helps out a lot so
there's many of the experiments after
all are about testing one hypothesis if
I turn on this does it help or not so
you want a control model and a very
completely equivalent model with only
that thing activated so that doesn't
that means that you don't have to run if
you have maybe a hundred models already
trained that can produce themselves a
hundred more models if you tune the
parameters that you don't want to do
that you just want to pick out maybe a
few well-known models activate that
feature that you want to test and see
the result and see if it's significative
significant the change that you observe
electron in the evaluation hi i I was
wondering since you're tested hundreds
of models you were shown in the plot of
precision versus recall I guess a lot of
them just different by the architecture
yeah number layers number numerous four
layers number of frozen layers others
might differ because of what you were
saying of choices like hair no hair in a
head etc I was just curious what is the
most surprising thing you came across
there if you can name any in terms of
like things that turn out to be
efficient which you wouldn't have
expected or things yourself would have
worked well and did pull it well some of
organ tations are unreasonably helpful
some datasets are really really bad so
for instance I can I can flat-out tell
you that I expected Katie to work very
well for us because we were processing
it in a way that the format matched what
we wanted so
we weren't just feeding that huge thing
inside the network and then expected to
work on an iPhone format but really
wasn't working and by digging we
realized how badly annotated it is for
our purposes how badly humans are
annotated and then there's a ton of
things that surprised me like if you're
playing around with with a segmentation
part of cocoa you'll find where people
just went nuts and decide and hated
their lives while annotating and just
wrote absurd things so yeah you see all
sorts of things we have time for one
more question so thanks for the talk and
it's faster to train a neural network
using transfer learning than to training
from scratch yeah very much so
yeah sure because if you're if you're
training over if you've got most of your
network frozen then the backpropagation
only reaches a certain point so it's a
lot it's a lot faster it changes from if
you're trying to to retain the full
thing over imagenet it might take
several days weeks and whereas if you
are models for instance training just a
few layers take hours yeah excellent
so can we give one more round of
applause
[Applause]